coluche comédien n'est pas harry 26 ans
de viol
ouais t'as vu son savoir à tous je viens
voir à coup alors que je bois pas par
exemple et les becs va pas ou que je
dois quoi on n'a qu'à faire comme si on
se connaissait on va se dire qu un ouais
comme ça ça sera mieux
non je mange bien parce que je vais
parce que j'aime ça quoi non mais je en
fait je mange pas beaucoup je mange un
petit peu de chaque chose quoi hein
c'est pour garder la ligne
la ligne genève aligne une grosse ligne
un trait que j'avais pas une ligue 1
très quand ça s'est passé collège p
début j'ai raté mon certificat d'études
et puis alors j'ai travaillé et puis
j'ai fait j'étais apprenti 14 squash pas
dans des métiers différents et j'ai
jamais réussi à en faire un sol en fait
je crois que tous les gens du métier ont
fait quatorze métiers quoi j'étais
fleuriste j'étais télégraphiste j'étais
marchand de légumes
j'ai travaillé chez un céramiste
je me souviens que il monte en a fait un
paquet aussi je crois que c'est normal
parce que comme on peut pas vraiment
apprendre à être doué pour faire ce
métier là quoi c'est comme écrivain a
pas d'école d'écrivain on est obligé de
d'essayer ailleurs vachement avant alors
avant après après ça j'ai fait mon
service militaire
c'est un truc à un moment il t'appelle
pour faire la guerre il n'y a pas la
guerre
et voilà au départ ils se foutent de ta
gueule mais tu fais comme si tu c'était
pas vrai toit et alors tu es censé
apprendre à faire la guerre aux russes
en plus est vraiment lamentable à ce que
les russes aux états prennent les
michael ils sont dix fois plus d'équipés
y toi et tu as vraiment pas impérial
alors j'ai envoyé chez le premier j'ai
rencontré et alors il m'a mis en prison
et comme on était bien mieux en prison
qu'ailleurs parce que par un travail
mais qu'après le maniement d'armes à
ramper dans la merde
et tout ça c'est très important pour
l'avenir de la france est alors interdit
de divulguer à qui que ce soit dans
quelle merde ensemble parce que c'est
très importante un bref ces secrets
militaires ce qui explique sa vie comme
il dit trouver que j'étais bien chez eux
m'ont gardé un mois de plus
c'était du rab alors comme j'avais
durable à la cantine me suis je leur
dois bien ça je vais là je vais leur
faire un petit mois façon j'étais par un
mois après j'étais chômeur alors talent
meslois marianne offre alors après j'ai
décidé que je travaillerai plus jamais
de ma vie jamais plus j'aurai un patron
jamais plus j'irai bosse et j'ai juré ma
mère que j'y retournerais plus parce que
c'est vraiment l'horreur quoi je veux
dire bon mais qui font la grève mais
c'est rien quoi il devrait mettre le feu
cette optique souhaite anarchiste de
saint médard franchement l'anarchie je
sais pas exactement ce que c'est je suis
connue schiste en fait politiquement toi
et on est 2 et l'autre veut pas
grandissant dans parce qu'il a peur de
passer pour un imbécile mais je sais pas
j'ai enfin bref anarchisme hip hop je
pense que c'est alors après ça j'ai fait
la manche c'est à dire que j'ai très
bien gagner ma vie à faire la quête dans
les restaurants de la rive gauche ça un
seul inconvénient c'est que depuis la
place maubert jusqu'au voie de l'amour
tard ça pue les herbes de provence parce
qu'ils font tous vertes de france parce
que c'est la mode
alors tu as vraiment envie de gerber je
peux plus supporter les herbes de
provence pour mais ça c'est pas grave on
gagne très bien sa vie on vit de rien ou
via l'hôtel j'ai vécu à l'hôtel pendant
trois ans doit bouffer restant tous les
jours avec la manche
et après ça j'ai commencé à faire du
cabaret alors là il a fallu que je
retourne chez ma mère parce qu'avec les
salaires de misère qu'on avait il était
plus question de goût free au restaurant
n'est que je couche à l'hôtel et puis
après ça j'ai rencontré romain bouteille
le grand romain bouteille lui même et il
avait l'idée de faire un saint café
théâtre qui existaient pas vraiment à
l'époque encore qu'il a complètement
créé de toutes pièces
il a fait le café de la gare qui a eu un
énorme succès il nous a appris à jouer
comédie nous appris ce que c'était du
spectacle qui est très important le
spectacle quand tu as compris pourquoi
les gens ont envie d'aller voir un
spectacle tu peux en faire
pourquoi coluche été choisi d'être un
comique je crois qu'on choisit pas bien
tout âge quand on est on est un petit
peu choisis par le parler donc mon à
quoi un celui qui est plus douée pour
faire pleurer il fait pleurer je suis
que plus doué pour faire rire il fait
rire mais ça correspondait aussi à ma
nature qui avait plutôt envie de faire
dire que mon physique aussi
le teasing veut dire je voudrais faire
croire aux gens que free jeune premier
au cinoche
j'aurais quand même vachement de boulot
alors que si je leur fait croire que
chez un petit goût à lunettes j'ai aucun
mal c'est mon cas d'influents bon
d'accord t'as pas les très très très
régulier